vegas is known as the entertainment
capital of the world
but that title goes beyond the strip to
community theaters that are trying to
get by during this pandemic
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us how local groups are coming
together to survive
the spotlight on local theater companies
is dark as
southern nevada theater groups struggle
to stay in business
during the pandemic every company is
trying to find its own way
to continue and they've lost revenue
we're doing everything
we can to coping with covet we're
relying solely on
on the the kindness of our patrons
[Music]
creative organizations like the
playhouse struggle financially
the las vegas theatrical venue shut the
doors five months
after opening because of the virus we
are still obligated to pay
certain bills and have zero income the
kovitt closures impacting theaters from
the community to the strip
but benjamin loewy says the current
restrictions miss the mark
we are being held to the same standards
as 2000 seat amphitheaters
and that's something that we are
struggling to keep up with our biggest
struggle right now is that we're
invisible to policy makers who try and
persevere
various local theater groups recently
formed the producers alliance of
southern nevada
those who make theater happen are
starting to come together
our first job is to band together so
that we can speak with one voice and
hopefully get
policies tailored to protect the local
arts community that right now is
overlooked a partnership to aid in the
recovery of the performing arts economy
and we all have things in the works but
we need
the help of the community help to make
sure the show goes on
and kovit is not the final curtain call
for local entertainment
kristin drummond 8 news now
eatmoreartvegas.com is sharing news
about all local art projects including
theaters
we'll post the link on our website where
you can search and find ways to help the
various groups right now